follow Lange focus on Facebook Twitter
and Instagram hello everyone welcome to
the line focus Channel and my name is
Paul today's topic is a language that
some of you have probably never heard of
but it's a fascinating topic and one
that's definitely worth a look
the topic is Quechua and in Quechua the
language is sometimes referred to as
lunacy me which means the people's
language if we include all varieties of
Quechua it is by far the most widely
spoken native language in South America
with between 8 and 10 million speakers
spread out across Peru Bolivia and
Ecuador as well as northern Argentina
and southern Colombia Spanish is now the
dominant language in all of those
countries but of course that wasn't
always the case even if you haven't
heard of Quechua you've most definitely
heard of the Inca civilization whose
capital was located at Cusco in
present-day Peru and whose empire was
the largest in the Americas in the
pre-colonial period and as their empire
expanded the language spreads to new
areas because it became the general
language or the lingua franca of the
areas under the Empire's control the
origin of Quechua is debated with some
people saying that it originated in the
Cusco area and others saying that it
originated in the central coastal area
of Peru throughout the time of Inca rule
Quechua was not a written language
records were only kept in kaput
a system of knotted strings that serve
as symbols or mnemonic reminders of
information
hippos are not fully understood but they
are not thought to represent the sound
or the structure of Quechua instead they
simply provide reminders of information
to be passed down orally Quechua did not
become a written language until the
Spanish conquest of the Inca Empire
which took place between 1532 and 1570
to Quechua continued to be spoken as a
lingua franca after the Spanish conquest
and the Catholic Church used Quechua in
its efforts to convert people spreading
the language even further the oldest
written record of Quechua is a book
written in 1560 by the missionary
Domingo de santo tomas called grammar or
art of the general language of the
indians of the royalty of Peru after the
Tupac Amaru rebellion of 1780 the
colonial power banned Quechua from
public use even Quechua attack
that were Pro colonial or pro-catholic
were banned and the language began to
decline after the Spanish American wars
of Independence from 1808 to 1833
Quechua had a brief revival but it has
gradually lost prestige and declined in
use one of the main reasons for the
decline of Quechua is the use of Spanish
as the language of education and of the
media and the use of Spanish as the main
language of national economy and with
economic development comes increased
urbanization when people move from their
local area to a major city it's
necessary to speak Spanish with the
majority of people who don't speak
Quechua Spanish is often thought of as
the language of prestige and of economic
opportunity for speakers of Quechua or
people whose parents speak Quechua often
see it as something low prestige and
something to avoid some Quechua speaking
parents avoid speaking Quechua with
their children at home and instead speak
to them in Spanish even in researching
this video and in looking for volunteers
to read the Quechua samples some people
told me that they themselves don't be
ketchup but that their friends parents
speak Quechua or that their uncle or
aunt speak Quechua Peru was the first
country to make Quechua an official
language in 1975 along with I Amara and
other native languages in Bolivia it's
been an official language along with 35
other native languages since 2006 in
Bolivia each regional government is
officially bilingual choosing both
Spanish and one of the other official
languages in Ecuador Quechua has had
semi official status since 2009 Spanish
is the main official language but
Quechua and Schwar are referred to as
official languages for intercultural
relations even though Quechua began to
be written after the Spanish conquest it
is still mainly a spoken language and it
isn't really written all that much and
there are various different standards of
orthography this is partly because
Quechua has spoken differently in
different places
Quechua is not really a single language
rather it is a series of closely related
groups of dialects and those groups of
dialects that have a high level of
mutual intelligibility can be considered
languages if there were one standard
written language that was widely
accepted and widely used throughout all
the different areas then it might be
able to be called a single
anguish because of that unifying force
but there is no such standard language
Quechua is divided into two major
dialect categories Quechua one and
Quechua two which are fairly distinct
from each other but there's a dialect
continuum within each category
Quechua one is spoken in central Peru
and is sometimes referred to as Y wash
Quechua - which is sometimes called
whomp ooh can be further subdivided into
three dialect groups there's Quechua 2a
in northern Peru Quechua to be northern
Quechua also known as Quechua which has
spoken mainly in Ecuador and southern
Colombia and Quechua to see southern
Quechua which includes the Quechua
spoken around Cusco in Bolivia and in
Argentina southern Quechua is the most
commonly spoken and the Cusco dialect is
often seen as the de facto standard
variety of Quechua even though it really
isn't the dialects within each of these
groups are largely intelligible and
there is some degree of intelligibility
between the different groups the lowest
degree of intelligibility is between
Quechua one and Quechua two even if both
varieties are located in Peru
the difference between Quechua one and
Quechua two seems to have resulted from
a split from proto Quechua the main
differences between them are in
vocabulary and morphology there are
differences in pronunciation too but
there are also pronunciation differences
within each group so what is Quechua
like let's look at some of the features
of Quechua focusing on southern Quechua
syntax Quechua is an sov language
subject-object-verb let's take a look at
an example sentence maria Ouachita rule
um this means Maria builds a house
word-for-word it's Maria house object
marker build third-person singular you
can see that the basic order is subject
object verb the subject comes at the
beginning of the sentence when there's
an explicit subject but it's possible to
have a complete sentence without the
subject at the beginning like la cita on
the end suffix at the end is a subject
suffix so it's often not necessary to
have a subject at the beginning a gruta
nation one of quechuas main features is
that it's highly agglutinative let's
look at an example of agglutination
using a noun me
she means cat let's add the plural
marker Cunha miss hakuna means cats or
the cats there's no definite article in
quechua so it depends on the context
let's add the word for with one me chiku
now on means with the cats but let's
move this over and add a different
suffix meaning you're Kiki
Nishiki quenelle one means with your
cats and if we take away one we have
Misha Kakuna which simply means York at
one more example using the word for road
yam add the plural marker Cunha and we
have yang Cunha roads then add the word
for on P yang Cunha P means on the roads
let's remove the word at the end that
slide this over and again we can add a
possessive suffix this time in GU
meaning there but it's awkward to have
these two nasal sounds right next to
each other with no vowel so you add me a
euphonic particle that has no meaning so
we have nian in kikuna which means
they're roads then at that post position
P again and we have Niang ninguna P
which means on their roads let's look at
an example of agglutination using a verb
we're starting with we Annie the
infinitive of the verb meaning to here
if we take away the Y at the end we now
have the verb stem to which we can add
suffixes first add e a subject pronoun
suffix meaning I so fiorini
means I here let's move this over and we
can add a past tense suffix to the stem
aha
now we have we added honey which means I
heard another example meaning I am
learning Quechua aruna Samhita otaku
Sahni aruna see me is the word for
Quechua as I said earlier and top is the
object marker suffix which shows that
lunacy me is the object but let's focus
on the verb yatta is the stem of the
verb meaning to know who is a suffix
which makes a verb reflexive or done to
oneself
so the otaku means learn saw is a
progressive suffix which shows that the
action is in progress now and knee is
the subject pronoun suffix meaning I one
feature of Quechua that will be
unfamiliar to speakers of many languages
is topic and focus
markers the topic marker indicates what
the topic or theme of the sentence is
the topic is always some information
that has been previously mentioned or
something that is presupposed
the focus marker indicates new
information or information that is not
presupposed or it shows some point of
contrast the topic marker is cop or cop
and the focus marker is important or me
let's look at a sentence being Lafitte
la de Haan this means who built the
house word for word it who focus marker
house object marker build past tense
third-person singular subject here the
focus marker is attached to the question
word to focus on the new information
that is being requested here's a
possible answer theater unless he's a
hard worker
this means it was Peter do who built the
house word for word it's Peter do focus
marker house object marker topic marker
build past suffix third-person singular
subject the focus marker is attached to
Peter do because he is the new
information being introduced the topic
marker is attached to house after the
object marker because the house is the
ongoing theme that was already
introduced earlier in the conversation
at potential markers that focus marker
has another function to show direct
evidence that something is true this is
a kind of evidential an indicator of the
source of information
another evidential marker is cha which
shows inference xi or ship which shows
here say something that you heard let's
look at an example sentence Adamu shun
me this means it is raining word for
word it rain sis locative particle which
indicates movement towards the speaker
progressive suffix third-person singular
subject evidential marker this
evidential me indicates that the speaker
has observed firsthand that it's raining
the next sentence is exactly the same
except for the evidential marker at the
end but i'm luciene job this means
something like I think it is raining the
marker jaw indicates that the speaker in
furs or guesses that it's raining the
next sentence
Adamu Shaanxi means something like I
heard it's raining the evidential
particle she
indicates that the speaker has been told
by someone that it's raining but they
have no first-hand evidence of it
Spanish loanwords Quechua uses a large
number of loan words from Spanish as
much as one-third of quechuas vocabulary
depending on the variety of Quechua and
the area here are some examples see the
visa from Spanish set a visa to fear
from Spanish Affair meaning driver
escuela the Spanish word for school and
liberal the Spanish word for book
instead of the Quechua word patada as
you can see ketch was a fascinating
language and one that is deeply
connected with the history and the
culture of its speakers and of the
countries where it is spoken the decline
of Quechua is unfortunate and the loss
of Quechua would be a very sad thing
indeed perhaps the key to preserving
Quechua is truly bilingual schooling and
more focused on Quechua literacy the
question of the day if there are any
native speakers of Quechua watching how
often do you speak Quechua and how often
do you speak Spanish does it depend on
the situation and for other people do
you notice any features of Quechua that
you've noticed in other languages be
sure to follow Leng focus on Facebook
Twitter and Instagram and again I'd like
to say thank you to all of my wonderful
patreon supporters especially these
excellent people right here on the
screen for their monthly pledges thank
you for watching and have a nice day
[Music]
you